(audience applauds)
- You're so colorful
and cute.
- What a lovely audience.
I'm very excited you're here.
I'm like a super fan.
I love everything you do.
I think you're so rad.
Do you wanna try some food?
I'm a good host.
We have food.
- Look, see?
- What do we got?
- Do you wanna try the steamer?
It's a little messy.
If you wanna try in a
commercial break or now,
whatever you feel.
- Hmm.
- But I'm gonna tell you what,
I've never had a steamed burger.
It's juicy.
It's true.
Don't get it on that pretty yellow neon.
I am gonna get this hair though.
Watch that.
Boo, boo, boo, boo, boop.
Okay.
I didn't want it to get in your food.
Isn't it good?
(audience chuckles)
It's delicious.
Do you not like it?
- Oh, no.
- That's a really good burger.
- Oh, I was like, oh no.
I just gave you something you don't like.
- No.
- I'm shocked that I picked
a burger over at pie.
- Mm.
- Because I love pie.
- Wait, I had a choice?
You didn't tell me I had a choice.
- Well, that one won out.
So you didn't get to pick.
- It's not greasy at all.
- I know.
It's very juicy.
- How did they make it?
- Steamed it.
I've never had that, anyway-
- But you would imagine it
to be dry if they did that.
- And let's be real.
I've been to a lot of games in my life.
I've never been to a place
where they actually have like-
I mean that's like a really good burger.
It's not like trash.
- Super juicy, I'm sorry.
Dude...
Is it okay to be talking about food
in front of all these
humans without giving them-
- It's so impolite and rude.
But that's what we're doing.
Yeah.
- I'm so sorry.
- Because COVID.
- By the way,
it's really good
- If you're ever gonna make a burger,
steam it.
- So delicious.
Sucks for y'all.
- It's super juicy.
- So wait, do you have a favorite snack?
I dunno, when you go to a game or anytime?
- I'm a big artichoke pizza fan.
- [Kelly] I love artichokes,
but I've never had artichoke pizza.
- Mm, it's so good.
- Okay.
- It's a New York thing.
- Like on 14th Street,
they have this really amazing pizzeria.
I don't know the name of it,
but I always end up there.
Like, it's open late at night.
And so you come home from the club
and, you know, you wanna
sober up real quick
and you have this amazing pizza.
- I do love New York pizza.
- Oh yeah, absolutely.
- So the new movie, I love it.
'Dungeons & Dragons: Honor Among Thieves.'
It's like, so different.
It remind me of a little-
Like the humor of Monty Python.
- Yeah.
- Which I love.
Like, I'm a huge Monty Python fan.
So like, is the-
I've never played the game.
Have you ever played the game?
Is it influenced or is it-
Does it stick directly-
- No, that's the beauty of it.
Like, you know, if you
didn't play the game,
you have that element of
just being in the adventure.
'Cause it's not like
"Jumanji" or anything,
- Yeah.
- Where you're watching a movie that-
or a story based on the
people playing the game.
It's more the adventure itself.
And so you can really just dive in and-
- Did you ever play when you were younger?
- Oh yeah, absolutely.
- Really?
- 16-
- People get into this.
- 17, 18.
Yeah, Jersey City-
- You have to have
like multiple people?
Like in order to-
- Yeah, absolutely.
And a really big imagination.
It's all about the imagination.
- I have that.
- Yeah, yeah.
- Okay.
- And if you ever wanna exercise it,
"Dungeons & Dragons" is
the perfect way to do that.
- Okay, exercise or just like-
- Exercise your imagination.
- I will do that.
I won't do the other one.
(Kelly & Michelle laugh)
Like, you just made it not fun, Michelle.
Wait a minute, made it weird.
No, so for those who have
never played the game,
can you try and explain like,
what's happening in the movie?
Like, what's happening?
- Yeah, I mean it's really...
You know, you have a bunch of...
kind of derelicts, you know,
who aren't really good at what they do.
It's slightly-
- You're pretty good at what you do.
- Well, I mean-
I mean we're-
- How is your character-
Holga's really good at what she does.
- Holga's good at maybe fighting
'cause she's a barbarian.
But she's bad at like, life stuff.
Like, finding boyfriends or
getting on with her family.
And like, everybody's got their flaws.
So all these flawed people,
you know, become a team.
And they go out on this mission
to get back at Edgin's daughter.
- [Kelly] Yes.
- And then that mission unites everybody
and makes them kind of like, very similar
to "Wizard of Oz."
To find your strength and your courage.
- Oh, that's true.
Yeah, meets Monty Python.
Yeah.
(Michelle laughs)
- It's quite funny in between.
- It is so funny.
Even Hugh-
Like, I was very surprised.
- Can I just say, Hugh is my favorite.
- Oh, my god.
The cast-
Like, whoever cast the show-
Or cast the movie did such a great job.
It's so well done.
Everyone's so different.
- We're so different.
- So wait, did the cast
ever play together?
Did y'all play around?
- Yeah, we did.
We did.
We got together with these
Wizards of the Coast.
And they're like a team of like-
They're the professionals, you know?
They kind of like maintain
the ethics and standards.
- Integrity of the game.
- The integrity of "Dungeons & Dragons."
And make sure that nobody messes that up.
And so, you know, Jonathan and
John who directed the movie,
they made sure that they checked in.
You know, the whole way.
When writing the script,
when developing the project.
Just to make sure that we
don't piss off the legacy.
- Especially gamers.
There's another show, "The Last of Us."
People are really-
If it's a game and it comes to that,
they get really devout,
like, what their thing is.
- You know what?
It's just-
When people find their niche
and their congregation-
- They don't want you
to mess with it.
- They don't want you to mess with it.
Because they they hold it precious.
And, you know, I respect that.
We're not here to mess
any of your dreams up.
We wanna accentuate it.
- I will say, I would
love to play the game.
I've actually had several
people here on the show
that have their own games going on.
People are really, really into it.
And I never knew that, but-
- It's so cool.
I just wish I was a dungeon master.
You know, you have to have
that dungeon master-
- Well, and it's called
a campaign or something?
- Yeah, so basically,
the Dungeon Master is the God Saturn
and he generates the
limitations of your gameplay.
So decides where in the
world of "Dungeons & Dragons"
you are and what the limitations
of your game play are.
Then you can choose your characters
and develop your characters.
And the dice is the element of chance.
It's like the physics,
the 50-50 of it all.
You roll them to fight, you
roll them to make decisions.
You roll them to use your powers.
And then you try to get
from point A to point B
under the Dungeon Master's restrictions.
- How have I never played this game?
- Dude, I think you'd love it?
- Hey band, y'all gotta play with me.
Someone play with me.
Okay, thanks Kyle.
Kyle's over there.
Kyle's holding it down for everyone.
I'm gonna get my band to play with me.
I wanna play.
So wait, there's another
blockbuster coming soon.
"Fast and Furious."
- Oh, yeah.
- So is there anything-
(audience applauds)
Is there anything you can say about it?
- You know, I just watched it.
And I gotta say, you know-
It's almost nostalgic because
we're coming to the end
of like a 23-year journey.
- Gosh.
- I gotta say after watching it,
I'm like, I still don't
understand how we're able
to surpass the last one that we did.
'Cause after going to
space, I was literally like,
what could we possibly do to top this?
You know what I mean?
I just don't understand.
- Do you think y'all did with this?
- I really do.
I really do.
And the beauty of it is, in a sense,
you're gonna be left a little incomplete
after the movie's over.
You're gonna be like-
- What?
- Wait a minute.
You can't-
No, no, no, no, no, no, no.
Movies don't end like this.
That's all I can say.
- Oh, my god.
That's the greatest teaser ever.
What?
Is it weird, you know,
we're talking about
you've been doing this,
you said like 23 years.
Like, that's not normal for, you know,
you to be around all these
actors from the beginning
and then have that family.
It's like a whole separate family.
- Yeah.
- What's that like?
- It's like a TV show, honey.
- You've grown up in that.
- It literally is very
similar to like a TV show.
We've seen each other grow up.
I'm the godmother to a
couple of Vince's kids.
Like, you know, we've seen-
We've had people leave us.
We just grew up together
and yeah, it is a family.
And it's insane that we've
lasted this long without,
you know, biting each other's heads off.
- I don't know if another
franchise has really done that,
in that sense, you know what I'm saying?
Like even with like, "Star Wars,"
that skipped years and
years and years, you know?
It's separate, it's different.
I don't know if I know a
franchise has done it like that.
That's incredible.
- Not with the original cast.
- That's what I mean.
- I think we did kind of
make history that way.
And me and-
I think Dom and Letty have the
longest standing relationship
in a feature film.
- Wow.
- Yeah.
23 years.
(audience applauds)
- Lasts longer than most real people.
- Yeah, I know.
I can't even last two
years with a partner, man.
I need some of that
lady action.
- But I'm great on film.
- I know.
I'm great on film apparently.